a pesar de la lluvia que en ti no duda
en ir a buscar madera flotante
por estos trozos de madera puede hacer
patas de fax sé que esta va a ser
solidaria sin cortes
quien team lleva tres años realizando
objetos con este material para recoger
la madera para una propiedad privada
hizo un trato con el propietario quien
le permite recoger lo que necesita a
veces también recurre a antiguos
carpinteros para obtener madera a un
menor precio que en fin decidió
convertir su gran pasión en su trabajo
durante el segundo confinamiento su
contrato temporal como mesero en un
restaurante no fue renovado y fue
entonces cuando decidió crear su
microempresas
principalmente hago lámparas o
candelabros accesorios de iluminación
con madera flotantes que recoge también
gimnasios para
sus creaciones cuestan entre 80 y 200
euros por el momento solo tiene dos o
tres pedidos al mes su presencia en
internet todavía no es muy fuerte por lo
que quentin utiliza sobre todo el boca a
boca para encontrar a sus clientes una
lámpara determinada su negocio aún no es
lo suficientemente grande como para
vivir de éste sólo le genera 150 euros
de ganancias al mes por lo tanto sus
padres lo apoyaron económicamente
desde que se levantaron las
restricciones retomó el servicio en su
antiguo restaurante ahora está empezando
un trabajo de medio tiempo como segundo
cocinero ideal para seguir desarrollando
su proyecto paralelamente con la
esperanza de que un día éste se
convierta en su actividad principal en
un año fueron creadas casi un millón de
empresas en francia un récord que puede
explicarse en parte por las medidas del
país para evitar los contagios en el
trabajo en marzo de 2020
julia trabajaba en el sector de la
comunicación con un contrato temporal
tuvo dos semanas de vacaciones forzosas
y luego empezó a teletrabajar
fue realmente durante estas vacaciones
forzosas de dos semanas en marzo de 2020
cuando me senté en una mesa y empecé a
crear mi primer diseño que el logotipo y
otras decisiones de mi marca
comenzó a crear pañuelos de seda
creaciones originales que ella misma
diseña tras desarrollar su proyecto
durante varios meses
finalmente creó su empresa en noviembre
de 2020 desde entonces ha tenido 200
pedidos y facturado 30 mil euros
pero aún no ha recuperado su inversión
financiera pues re invierte todo el
dinero que gana en seda virgen una
materia prima cara y por supuesto hay
que pagar impuestos
actualmente mi marca no es una actividad
que me permite mantenerme por lo que
sigo teniendo mi trabajo al mismo tiempo
mi contrato terminará pronto así que
intentaré concentrarme plenamente en la
marca para seguir desarrollándola y
luego veré en 23 meses si puedo
encontrar un trabajo complementario oa
medio tiempo
me tocó a cúter
fatma y matilde hicieron de su negocio
su trabajo a tiempo completo
tantos
inaugurada en enero de 2021 su agencia
de viajes cuenta con una facturación
inicial de 10 mil euros
en tanto la pandemia ha sido una
oportunidad para que muchas personas se
cuestionen su relación con la naturaleza
su concepto parece encontrar un público
organizamos fines de semana con destinos
empresa
no habíamos previsto
el tipo de viaje posible con y con
visión así que la crisis fue también una
oportunidad para desarrollar todo esto a
pesar de la reapertura de las fronteras
francesas el 3 de mayo las reservas en
la agencia de viajes local siguen
aumentando incluso se crearon dos
puestos de prácticas para ayudar con el
aumento de las labores de la empresa
y nuestros practicantes
fatma y matilde no pueden pagarles
todavía pero tienen la intención de
hacerlo en cuanto puedan permitírselo
si vamos
las dos amigas supieron aprovechar al
máximo el difícil periodo de la pandemia
tengo confianza en la empresa es cierto
que empezamos en un contexto difícil de
crisis sanitaria lo que nos hizo más
fuertes y resilientes y esto también dio
lugar a una nueva tendencia de consumo
un consumo más sostenible y también a la
tendencia del último slow así que he
confiado en el futuro acción la crisis
del covent 19 les dio tiempo a muchos
franceses para emprender el proyecto de
sus sueños en francia el período
posterior a la crisis ha visto
desaparecer gradualmente los mecanismos
puestos en marcha y el reto para los
emprendedores del cob it es ahora
sobrevivir al mundo de después